you know it was really interesting to me
just before you said wwf
and god i mean when did the f go away
and turn into an e was
like 2002 2004
man i think it was even yeah it's
somewhere around 2000
something uh you're probably in the
ballpark it might have been 2001 even i
don't remember
not 2002. so somewhere along with the
way it happened it was because
they were sharing the letters with world
wildlife fund
yeah with that little panda bear and
then finally i think world wildlife fun
got pissed off because of wwe
and they do a lot of great things so
whatever but the wwf is such a global
brand and it got so big
that i think that you know people were
confusing
who the wwf represented they had a
trademark
so vince decided hey man let's go this
direction and vince being the visionary
that he did
made that call and it upset me because i
was a professional wrestler when all of
a sudden you want to call me an
entertainer or a sports entertainer
that didn't really fit well with me so
and really
it encompasses everything that we do but
when the bell rings you're in a 20 by 20
squared circle
and that's where the magic happens and
that is wrestling which is a form of
entertainment
right yeah i did man i'm glad i asked
that dude that was funny question that
was cool
yeah dude